macaroni and cheese scented air
fresheners and bacon and egg earrings
it's episode 19
this clock tells the correct time except
it runs backwards and thailand unique
will sell you a bottle of whiskey with a
cobra in it delicious chocolate covered
silk worms a can of barbecue scorpions
or a nice bag of edible pregnant
crickets if the thought of eating bugs
leaves you with cold feet make them
colder with this snowball shooting
crossbow and then warm them back up with
these usb powered heated slippers or
show your team spirit with vat 19's
giant puffy nfl sneaker slippers while
feeding your baby with an enterprise
spoon that can drip food all over a
flashing led tricky bib your bib of
course should be formal buy a baby
rattle that makes your baby look buff
and when they get older don't give them
army men give them break dance men or
treat yourself to a cute cuddly stuffed
animal cupcake
a pistol with a cowboy hat a slice of
pizza a stack of pancakes or my favorite
the zebra rabbit with a mustache
get your lady a pair of hand-painted
star wars shoes or these eye shadows
from geek chic cosmetics based on the
colors of the mushroom kingdom oh and
don't forget this shade of lipstick it's
called hipster ariel be even hipper with
a levitating lamp that looks like it's
been slashed by a lightsaber and here's
a wireframe you can use to make any
chair suggest the idea of a throne
ferrofluids are colloids containing
magnetic material so they respond to
magnetic fields and their own cohesion
and surface tension you can buy a whole
play kit or a liter of the stuff now
just don't drink it instead drink some
civet coffee this coffee is produced by
having civets run around eating the very
best beans they find these guys swallow
it digest it and enzymes in their
intestines change the beans which they
poop out completely whole so farmers
collect the poop wash it off roast the
beans and produce for you the best
smoothest and most expensive coffee on
earth
full disclosure i bought some of this
last year for my dad on father's day and
it was delicious i'm gonna shout out
science bob now you lean backers know
him his site's store is cool he's got
smoke shooting guns and smoke wands and
owl pellets that you can dissect to get
rap bones out of science for the win and
as always thanks for watching
you